- In a moment of uncertainty
for so many of us.
A moment when so many of
us are asking ourselves
and each other what we
can do for our country.
I can't think of a more
important lesson to draw upon
than this key fact, that
it's up to all of us.
Young people and aged are at heart
to come together, find
out what beliefs we share
and work towards solutions.
Tonight is an important
one for many reasons.
Tonight we pay tribute
to the power of politics.
To enable young Americans to have a real,
tangible, positive impact
on their community.
And tonight we celebrate the
capacity for public service
outside of elected office, to
take on difficult challenges
with a new perspective.
We can all make a difference
and tonight we honor two
people whose lives and careers
prove that no matter how
difficult the challenge may seem
and how unfavorable the odds may be,
it's possible to do a
great deal of constructive
and lasting work in your
community and beyond.